last time on the ozempic Diaries hey
there just thought I'd do a quick
awesome pick check-in it is day 44 in my
journey I have done hang on a second
seven doses so four at .25 milligrams
and three at point five I'm down about
four pounds so you know that's not too
bad my last dose of the 0.5 next week
I'll be up at the one milligrams
I do feel like ozempic right now is
acting as my like support system and
it's not allowing me to overeat that's
one thing that I will say like I'm not
overeating at all
hey everyone welcome back to Abby's
kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be catching back up with my
friend and business partner ginger on
month three of our Olympic journey and
today we'll be discussing rapid weight
loss cooking without an appetite
transparency and a zenpic for food noise
a quick disclaimer here that this video
includes numbers calories Extreme Weight
Loss discussion also please note that
the individual in the series is not my
client so any suggestions are for
general knowledge and education purposes
only also a reminder that the purpose of
this series isn't to promote ozempic or
weight loss in general is to counter a
lot of the myths and disinformation
about ozempic with honesty transparency
and evidence-based practice Evelyn's
needs are going to be unique and should
always be discussed one-on-one with your
health care provider so to quickly just
catch us all up Ginger did a month of
0.25 milligrams then a month at 0.5 and
in this video she'll be doing the one
milligram dose for a month and starting
the 1.5 milligram dose so in other words
we are finally reaching the clinical
dosage now before we get talking to
Ginger let's take a look at some of her
video diaries this is my second dose at
one milligram I will say that I've lost
another couple pounds this week this
past week I felt like it was
like it was you know I've been looking
at food I'm like man it doesn't really
like impress me much the one thing I
will say that when I took the one
milligram doses that I'm exhausted I've
never been so tired of my life so
ozethic exhaustion is quirky it actually
apparently doesn't affect everyone and
is still considered a more rare side
effect and it's probably because a lot
of people who are on ozempic also have
high blood sugars so if you take it for
weight loss instead while having healthy
normal blood sugar levels then it's
possible that it can lower your blood
sugar lower than what you're used to and
can cause temporary lethargy as your
body just kind of gets used to it I
actually had the same experience when I
was put on Metformin for IVF because my
blood sugars were normal before I took
the drug so I ended up getting these
really uncomfortable lows as a not so
great side effect so again as
uncomfortable as it is this should level
out over time it is my third dose of
confused and a little bit sad because I
didn't see any progress this week and I
worked out every single day except
yesterday including three of those days
being double headers I'm getting a
little
concerned I gained a pound this week I'm
still eating I'm just not thinking about
food all the time
which I guess is good it's just it's so
hard not to see the progress
that I want to see so I don't know so
that's why weekly weigh-ins aren't
always representative of progress
especially without any kind of
professional one-on-one guidance if I
were gingers Rd and I was doing these
measurements and weigh-ins I would also
be looking at these blips in the context
of what else might be going on that day
or week so for example where are you in
your cycle did you eat a very salty meal
the night before if you were to weigh
yourself in a few days would it be
different I really encourage people not
to get too hung up on the individual
numbers on individual days the fact that
she's not thinking about food all the
time feels like huge progress to me even
if it resulted in very little weight
loss this week just imagine how much
space that opens up in your mind and
life for things that bring you Joy and
over time as you're thinking and
obsessing less over food the weight very
likely will come down I also you know
after the last conversation with Abby I
don't think I ate very well
so I went to farm boy which is my
favorite go-to and picked up like
pre-made salads for this week some
salmon
um some veg we'll see how that goes I'm
just like not in the mood to cook listen
I'm rarely in the mood to cook now that
I've got kids who are just gonna Chuck
it on the ground so no judgment for me
on that but I do think that obviously
losing interest in food and reducing the
drive to eat is absolutely going to have
the side effect of reducing the drive to
do the labor of making the food like the
food is kind of the fun part but we
still need to nourish ourselves even
when we don't really feel like it so
some other really easy convenient
options include rotisserie chicken
canned tuna Frozen cooked shrimp Frozen
egg bites smoothie freezer packets
frozen turkey burgers pre-cooked whole
grain pouches or just Add Water oats
there's also now a ton of grocery store
meal kits where you can just kind of
like dump everything into the pan so at
least you don't have to do the mentally
labor of deciding what to make one ounce
of cheese
donate me
Ginger she knew I was gonna have to say
something about this and I will to her
but I get the old diet habits die hard
and Ginger's Paulie spent a lot of her
life putting these on a scale but the
goal for us on ozempic is to no longer
need to track or meticulously weight
portions so we need to start to get used
to feeling and honoring those new Hunger
and fullness cues and that means kind of
going in blind so I would personally
just kind of cut a few slices of cheese
and simply eat until satiated see what
that feeling feels like and obviously we
want to tackle one thing at a time and
that Letting Go piece is key but once
we've got that down then of course we
can think about turning it into hunger
crush and combo by adding an egg or two
and some toast and fruit so I really
think that the experience of just
letting go of some of those old diet
crutches is the really important piece
here you gotta trust ozempic to do its
job because as ginger has started self
it's like her little helper her little
best friend in her back pocket give your
body the chance to relearn some of these
skills because that is what makes ozepik
different from any other diet you've
ever been on I'm still at one milligram
it will be my last dose at one milligram
next week I will be going up to 1.5 I
saw a pretty significant weight loss
this week even though I feel like I ate
which was is pretty good so I was down
2.4 pounds in the last week in terms of
symptoms still really tired still of the
diarrhea not relieving nausea although
there was one day this past week where I
just really I don't know if it was just
that I wasn't hungry or was nauseous but
I started drinking bone broth when that
was happening and I actually think it's
really helping the whole process so
upping my water intake so this will be
the first thing I have this morning
really taking coffee out of my diet
which is crazy I'm upping my water and
I'm adding in bone broth okay I love
this for us cutting down the coffee as
we discussed more water and some bone
broth this 100 makes sense to me there's
nothing magical about bone broth but
it's probably helping with symptom
management because a broth is mainly
water so again it's adding lots of
hydration and fluids are also better
tolerated than solids because they don't
require a lot of digestion when you're
feeling nauseous and B bone broth
contains electrolytes which may be
depleted from diarrhea and also protein
which has been shown to help improve
nausea symptoms better than any kind of
like really high fat or higher Sugar
Foods so this is great when you're not
feeling your best and you need a little
nourishment bone broth is a great way to
kind of like stimulate the appetite and
get a little bit of fluids and
nourishment in Canadians in case you
didn't know this as you get up past the
one milligram dose which is the
therapeutic dose for diabetes and you go
to 1.5 or 2 milligrams we do not yet
have the eight milligram pen in can
Canada so I went to upgrade or up my
dose to the 1.5 this week and I had to
pay for two pens so that took me over
500 for this month I've only budgeted
270 dollars which is the cost to me out
of pocket in order to sustain this I
guess I'm gonna have to now wrap my head
until that eight milligram pen comes in
about that extra fee that is a lot like
Americans let me know is it better or
worse for you because at least I think
it's somewhat covered by our health care
but yeah even 270 dollars a month is a
lot of a commitment especially when
we're thinking this is a lifelong
commitment now the one milligram I'm
really starting to see a little bit more
of a drastic change case in point as of
last week I'm down 12 pounds and I've
lost a total of 12 inches just over 12
inches I know Ginger was pretty worried
that it wasn't working for her or maybe
it wasn't working fast enough there's
always so much going on in our head when
we start these kind of medications so
you know there's definitely some folks
who will only need to take 0.5
milligrams long term but most folks will
probably need between one to two
milligrams to have the desired effect
now I know ginger has a lot to update us
on so let's get chatting all right
Ginger so nice to see you again hi hi
okay so first things first you tell
everyone as like a quick little recap
why you're doing this and why we're even
doing this together just very quickly on
both sides of my family we suffer from
obesity diabetes heart issues after I
went through quite a lot of hormone
treatment for egg freezing and I had
some surgery I had my gallbladder
removed and I had covered for about a
year like I was stagnant like I couldn't
move and I just put on too much weight
that was healthy for me like to the
point where I didn't want to move and
that's not like me so I talk to my
doctor we consulted with internal
medicine we talked we consulted with the
weight loss clinic in Ottawa and
basically the answer was if I go on
ozempic now not only will it help me you
know drop some of this weight uh
probably a little bit quicker than I
would be able to on my own but it would
be a preventative measure not to get
diabetes and hurt issues so that's kind
of the research that's coming out now is
that it is quite a life-altering drug
especially for those who suffer or who
have family histories of diabetes and
heart issues you know we've washed your
your Clips but tell me like first of all
how are you feeling like symptom-wise
how are you feeling today because things
are always changing well
great uh considering I went to a wedding
last night
I'm alive and well and you know I didn't
over drink actually that's one of the
symptoms or the side effects of of this
drug is you kind of lose the desire for
a lot of things you were previously like
you were jonesing for so things like
alcohol things like sweets like it's
just oh my my desire for those have been
drastically cut back so um so I feel
great so I never have these wild
hangovers anymore which is amazing and
like I can maybe have like two glasses
of wine
that is amazing what a feeling to uh
it's pretty amazing yeah and so tell me
a little about progress wise where were
you at since you've lost weight and done
some numbers here today is actually the
four month Mark so I've been on this
journey for four months now
um so I will be starting two milligrams
today I know
nervous because this is the dose where
everybody says this is where they
experience symptoms so I'm I'm looking
forward to our next chat to see if I
actually have the symptoms that
everybody's experiencing at this dose
but I've gone really gradually so I'm
hoping for the best but it's been four
months I've lost 19 pounds wow
this one and a half dose has been the
Catalyst of that real like no I don't
want this I'm gonna have a cup of bone
broth and you know some lactose free
cottage cheese and an egg instead like
that's been it's mind-blowing to me how
it's changed really what I'm craving wow
yeah so I'm very pleased I'm very very
pleased with the results it's been slow
and because it's been slow you know I've
yo-yo diet my whole diet in my whole
life preached anybody watching we you
know we're in this together and I will
say like when you lose weight fast so I
mean I've tried Atkins I've tried it all
like low carb you know all all these
things when you lose weight fast you
tend to be skinny fat you know and
whereas because I've been losing it
quite a bit slower and just on like a
really nice Pace I have it also I think
I've mentioned this I work out a lot
like I'm doing so much Pilates I'm
probably at Pilates like four to six
times a week and I'm like playing tennis
I do know that I have to get my cardio
up in order to but the problem is when I
get my cardio up I get hungry again so
I'm not really I haven't really invested
a lot in the cardio piece so I don't
know how his epic will affect that
hunger so stay tuned because I had kind
of earmarked September as being the
month just giving myself I needed to get
some weight off so that it didn't impact
my knees right you've told you took that
yeah yeah so now that I've gotten this
19 pounds off I'm ready to like get back
on the bike get back out and run things
like that so I will let you know how if
that impacts my Hunger overall and that
you know I was gonna ask you about
non-weight victories but just the idea
of you being able to get back on the
bike and run which are things that I
know bring you Joy that's a huge
non-weight victory
I love it I love it like here I am out
of town and I'm like researching I'm
like okay well it's Toronto so there's
every weight or every not wait sorry
every gym class and possible so I'm like
okay what can I do tonight at 6 30.
there's so many I'm so pumped that is a
huge on scale victory for me wow
inches too like listen I'm fitting into
like smaller pants that I've just been
have like they've been in my my you know
dresser or my closet just waiting to
come out again I couldn't believe it
like when I put them on I'm like oh my
God here we are again excellent
I was so scared to put them on well I
mean it must feel feel really good to to
be hitting these Milestones
um and I know you mentioned you know
you're feeling really good today tell me
about some of the things that have
helped manage your symptoms I know we've
talked you've talked about water and
bone broth amazing
um now that your symptoms are kind of
subsiding what is your diet looking like
right like right now other than the lone
piece of cheese Ginger because you know
I was gonna tell y'all talk to you about
that girl this is the problem so I get
into these these periods where I'm like
so focused on the food and the diet
aspect of things and that's where I'm
kind of like stop it because that's what
I don't want and that's why we talked
about this drug and that's why we wanted
to go on it because I wanted my body my
brain to make those decisions without me
having to take the scale out and weigh
it yes I was doing that a lot it was
almost like I was inspired because like
I was losing the weight and I'm like
okay well now I don't want to like
overeat my calories and here's the thing
so the in the comment section which is
one of the reasons why I wanted to we we
wanted to recap you know what we were
going through and why we were doing this
and I want everybody to know and and you
want everybody to know the situation and
we want to let's just a little playback
but a lot of people were like you're
eating too many calories if you're not
losing weight and it was like oh maybe
that is it you know and and that's why I
just it was reading those comments in
the sense that got me kind of to take
out the skin scale again and to focus on
it but I put it away as soon as I
videotaped that one I'm like oh my God
I'm here I am doing this I gotta
videotape this show her because I've
been doing it a couple of times and I
don't want to do it this is a good
reminder for folks who you know just
pretend like you've got me watching and
I'm gonna tell you to hunger crushing
combo it friends
um but also a really good reminder that
you know just so everybody knows the
clips you see are such a small snippet
of your real life every single day and
that goes for what you see influencers
post as well if you feel possessed to
leave comments in the comments section
of other people's you know recipes or
what in days to say oh yeah no wonder
you're fat you ate a donut have a think
that you don't know what they ate
earlier on the day you don't know what
they ate the next day you don't know
what they ate over the course of the
week so you really can't say you're not
tracking their calories you're not there
My Fitness Pal app so just keep in the
mind that that it doesn't tell this
whole story what we see online so ginger
be kind to yourself
um and and yeah just know that the
purpose for this drug is to be able to
reprogram your brain so that you don't
have to make those kinds of calculated
decisions or or lean on these external
indicators of your fullness so in one of
the clips that I watched of yours you
mentioned that people are starting to
notice your your weight loss and you
said you know one of your tennis
Partners said that she can tell that
you've been working out which you
obviously have she's can see you doing
it do you ever tell people that you're
on a subject are you open you know when
they comment on your weight loss what do
you say yes
very open because I realized that I am
getting some assistance so and because I
don't want to go into the Trap of
dieting and the trap of you look good so
that equates to your value and working
hard like I'm really trying not to go
there I don't say oh thanks it's ozempic
but I say thank you so much and if we go
into a bigger conversation about what
I'm doing then I will tell them because
I really think like it's not just
ozempic I'm sorry it's not yes it's
helping with the brain and the gut
connection and it's really helping curb
those Cravings that I so used to like
want like the pasta this the sweets oh
my God the sweets like it's just gone
and it's that's the radical difference
for me so I am being open and honest
about it I think it's important because
I think if anybody wants to make a
change in their life I think knowing
that there are tools but not crutches is
really important yeah I I think that's
absolutely true and you know I I always
say I don't think anyone owes anyone an
explanation or information when it comes
to their body or their health you know
and you Ginger you're not an influencer
that's out there coming on Instagram
saying like oh look at me I lost 50
pounds by doing this program and you can
buy it for me from 199
et cetera Etc like that to me is
unethical that's kind of like the Ali
Larter liposuction gate and Legally
Blonde situation where you know they're
trying to sell you on on their body as
their business card when perhaps they
had plastic surgery or in this case are
using ozempic but I yeah I I applaud you
for for coming out here and being open
with everyone on this journey to try to
help to destigmatize these things which
at the end of the days is I think really
important that we need to destigmatize
medication and we need to destigmatize
people in larger body taking efforts to
improve their health if that's what they
choose to do
um and making choices about their own
body and what feels good to them young
exactly and and you know there's the
opposite argument Abby I think we've
spoken about this as well is there's the
opposite argument that you know if we're
trying to destigmatize what this drug
could do what about people saying oh
you're overweight just take ozampic like
we don't want to create that either so
I'm actually making a conscious effort
that when I see somebody who looks
fantastic I'm not commenting on their
body anymore because I don't want to
imply anything so I'm saying you look so
happy like I love you so
I love that that's actually a general
rule of mine I just generally do not
comment on people's bodies whether they
look different whether they look the
same whatever it may be comment I like
your dress I like your purse I like you
know you look super happy you know
you're you're glowing you know whatever
it may be there's something there that
they can take from it whatever they want
but you're not specifically adding fuel
to that fire because we never know why
someone's body looks the way that it
does we don't know if what if they've
lost weight because of illness we don't
know if they've lost weight because of
sadness or a disordered eating Etc we
never want to reinforce that we know
that criticism doesn't help motivate
people that making them feel shamed
about their body doesn't make them want
to exercise or eat healthier it
typically does the opposite it drives
them further into whatever behaviors
landed them there in the first place so
that's just a general rule of thumb to
everyone keep your opinions of people's
bodies to themselves I think when you
really think about it it's like why are
you paying such close attention to my
body anyway like that's us so anyways
that's how I always think about it I'm
like it's kind of gross so I think
that's good for everyone now
two sides to the coin you know two sides
story we'll see what happens in a year
from now I wish celebrities who are 140
pounds weren't taking it to get to the
vanity 115 120. uh you know unless
they're dealing with PCOS right or
history of diabetes or a history of
heart disease unless they're trying to
treat something proactively right which
we'll never know so it's really not up
to us to make criticisms or judgments in
general you're right I just think the
media has kind of run rampant with this
storyline and it's doing a disservice to
all of us totally yeah but it's been
really good for Nova norvo or Nova it's
a company that creates has been huge the
media typically doesn't do us much good
let's be honest so I want to actually
get to some of the comments and
questions that I saw come up in the last
video and there was actually a lot of
comments about this idea of food noise
so there was one person who said the
absence of food noise that I've
experienced on Jose because being worth
its weight in gold I didn't realize how
much I'm exhausted myself mentally
thinking about food I was like is this
what it's like to be a normal person
it's so helpful and this me I don't know
Ginger I know you've experienced this
this seems like such a huge non-weight
Victory give me your your thoughts huge
right actually I'm going to put this in
another way for people who may not have
the food noise anxiety Until you realize
that that sense of worry is actually a
disconnect you know anxiety is the
perfect way to describe what the food
noise is so very similar thing I
remember asking friends like like if you
said the wrong thing to someone do you
not worry about that for five days days
and they were like no that's when I knew
something was wrong same same when I
talked to my husband at some of my my
thoughts and I realize how different I
am I'm like oh not everyone stays up
late at night ruminating over a simple
conversation with a stranger okay
I have both yeah yeah
but no the food noise when that being
gone it's so true what this person said
because that mental exhaustion is real
you get it with anxiety you get it with
food noise I mean I used to wake up
thinking about food where like it's
almost like this I don't know if it was
that mentality of scarcity like where's
my next meal gonna come from am I gonna
eat lunch like what am I gonna do how am
I gonna plan my day okay what's the work
back schedule you know how am I gonna
get come on yeah it's a lot are you
hungry banana yeah you know get an egg
you know totally but I never never had
that and you know there was another
really interesting uh question about
food noise so Aaron asks should those
epic be available for everyone who has
food noise and who can't eat intuitively
and who maybe are not living in a larger
body I don't know what your thoughts are
on this Ginger but I will say that
obviously this is ultimately a question
for doctors and researchers in this
field from my perspective as a dietitian
and also someone who has an anxiety like
you and have experienced a lot of Psych
drugs and things like that I think with
all medications there are risks and
benefits here so weight loss may be a
benefit to someone but it may be a risk
to another person I know Society always
thinks if weight loss as this like good
thing but it wouldn't be a good thing
for me for example like I wouldn't see
that as a benefit so typically folks
with food noise from like reward system
disruptions do tend to gain weight
whereas some folks have food noise
because of caloric restriction so the
former may be a candidate while the
latter it would be contraindicated so
again I think that it's possible but I I
think that would be something that you'd
have to discuss one-on-one with your
doctor to weigh those risks and benefits
totally and and I'm I'm not a doctor but
when I play the scenarios in my head and
even my personal journey to where I had
to go to actually feel the food noise
stop maybe somebody in a smaller body
only needs 0.25 for the food noise but
not the weight like maybe the weight
loss doesn't happen there right you know
so I don't know yeah there was a study
that came out Abby uh and I think we
talked about this one as well but it was
did scientists just discover the cure
for addiction they're tackling me three
things because this is what you know the
I think it's the food noise alcohol and
smoking so apparently those are three
things that have most people who start
ozampic have stopped doing I do wonder
if they're gonna start tampering with it
maybe so that there is no weight loss
component I don't know yeah we're gonna
see how this technology can be applied
to other uh comorbidities and things
like that because yes there's definitely
a lot of overlap here and I've got a
question for you about that Ginger you
know obviously you came into this
Desiring weight loss and wanting to
reduce your genetic risk of diabetes and
chronic disease but if you were not to
lose any weight on this drug would
reducing the food noise be worth some of
the side effects and costs and
everything else associated with taking
those that big would there be any
benefit to you even without that weight
loss piece that's a great question I
think yes in the sense that the mental
exhaustion is just gone in the sense
that sometimes now I have to go to a
menu and really think about what I'm
eating instead of just enjoying what
might be good in that sense Maybe not
maybe I wouldn't want to take it because
now I do have to really think oh is that
fried oh does that have dairy oh that's
really going to affect me you know like
which is fine and I actually I feel much
better having a salad with grilled
chicken like I feel that much better so
hi thanks for all those tips you know
yeah shocker
um I think if it allowed me not to gain
more weight and to just be neutral and
just live then yes I think it's a
worthwhile tool so long as I wasn't
overeating and just not gaining a lot of
it because the important thing for me
obviously is to take the weight off my
knee so that I can move right and I have
a really interesting
um fear in this space from uh John and
Stacy they said my fear with stigma is
that people will start to say oh just go
on ozempic to anyone that they perceive
to be unhealthy or overweight it will be
yet another way of blaming and shaming
people for being overweight personal
choice is important and I support body
autonomy and all of us choosing what's
healthy for us but I feel this is going
to set us back in the body acceptance
movement and Society moving towards
allowing us to all be different what are
your thoughts well I think we talked we
covered yes right yeah we did we talked
about this sort of like so John and
Stacy you kind of just nailed what we
were yeah talking about and I even
talked about this back in my original
and pick video when I was kind of just
sharing my in the moment fears and
hesitations about ozempic you know I am
scared that when I see already thin
folks who maybe have normal blood sugars
and healthy body weights take those then
our perception of what a healthy weight
looks like or what healthy looks like
again becomes even more skewed than I
think it already is I think you know for
one we can't we can't look at someone
and determine if they are healthy that
dichotomy it's going to become even more
black and white in people's minds and I
think as we've already established this
drug is very expensive you know and so
of course this opportunity is going to
be limited to folks who are financially
able to access it and that is unfair in
a lot of ways because then again we are
granting people the ability to have
health or to look a certain way and
therefore be not judged by the populace
who have ideas about what is healthy
what is not healthy or what's a healthy
look is going to be limited to those who
can afford it that said as we just
established I think there are a lot of
people who are prone to food noise and
other reward system disruptions for whom
a drug like ozempic that helps to
silence that noise can basically get
them their life back so yeah there's
there's a lot of interesting studies and
research emerging specifically about
ozone pick for these reward system
disruptions like you said addiction and
things like that and also for ozempic's
wider benefits for improving mood and
well-being and just ability to perform
daily activities so I will never I will
never stand in the way of somebody being
able to access happiness whatever that
may look like I never want to speak out
against that because that's going to be
different for everyone of course that's
going to come with disadvantages for
some populations but I don't think that
means that it's wrong or immoral for
people to have access to some of these
medications that do change lives totally
and I think John and Stacy's comment I
think we have to keep that in our back
pocket and keep like coming back to that
as more studies come out as we keep
talking about this you know as we
continue to like keep our finger on the
pulse of what people are saying like I'm
reading all the Reddit threads like
there's will go be weight loss there's
an ozempic thread like there's lots of
really good threads to go to for support
and to just like read up on what people
are experiencing and because yeah I
think the body acceptance movement and
body positivity movement could be at
risk like it is very very real however
as much as I want to accept how I look
it doesn't necessarily make me super
happy so and I know that's a societal
problem and I just don't know how to fix
it other than feeling better about
myself from the inside out right so
that's why I like the approaching it you
look happy or you look like you're
glowing it's going to be a struggle but
I think we should keep revisiting this
comment because I think it's a really
really important comment and I think
yeah you could come up with so many
Myriad of ways and Avi I never even
thought about the wealth disparity issue
you know wealth is health or health as
well to kind of like with sitting back
when you were saying that I'm like oh
God yeah I never thought about that I
mean it is much more cost effective to
get the drug in Canada than it is to get
it in the state and yes we have an
obesity problem in Canada but there's a
huge obesity problem in the state so I
mean we can't solve everybody's problems
like nobody can sell a drug can't solve
everybody's problems but I do wonder
what the drug the impact of the drug
could have on Health Care overall in
Canada we cover so many costs related to
obesity and malnutrition as people get
older like diabetes like heart issues
and I do wonder if we took preventative
stance what that could look like for the
overall cost Savings of our Health Care
system now this is Canada specific
obviously because we have we pay into
our Health Care system and it's um we
have free well it's not free it's not
free it comes out of our income taxes so
anybody who says Healthcare is not free
right but we do have a Health Care
system that is available to all I think
it's quite obvious that socioeconomic
status does play a role in weight
discrepancies and health discrepancies
Across the Nation in Canada in the
United States in a lot of these Western
countries so I think whether or not this
is going to make those discrepancies
even greater or in other ways possibly
close a gap we're just going to have to
find out you know yes this drug has been
around for a long time but it hasn't
been used by so many people at the same
time in history specifically for weight
loss so we're going to have to kind of
see what happens and and how it affects
our economy how it affects Public Health
all of those things so yes we're keeping
our eyes on that and also how it affects
mental health too in the mental health
of the general population and I'm sure
there will be research coming out about
that because we always evaluate the
mental health risks of drugs and this
has become such a big one this is not
like a drug we've ever had access to
before where it's just something oh yeah
somebody who needs that takes you know
takes that drug no this is like people
know what a zenpick is exactly just
you know I sometimes I think back I'm
like I wonder if those voluptuous women
in those Renaissance paintings think
about our generation like probably I
think they have all this money and
they're eating less like it makes no
sense they're thinking that's what the
peasants did they didn't eat very much
we want to Feast oh my God gosh I'm like
you know Society is backwards when the
healthy food is double the price the
cheap you know the processed food again
and this is partially why we see these
discrepancies in health in folks in
lower socioeconomic uh status groups and
so yeah we'll be adding a drug that
costs upwards of a thousand dollars a
month to the equation never mind healthy
fruits and vegetables they certainly are
not going to be able to afford that um
but again let's see where this goes
things are always changing when it comes
to price access all of those things if
we see that a drug like this could make
such a huge impact on our health care
then it may be in the financial interest
of the government to subsidize and
things like that so again we're going to
keep our eyes we're not going to know
that for another year to five years Etc
so let's keep our fingers on that Ginger
thank you so much for sharing your
journey I know it's so helpful for so
many people who are following along
folks please be kind this time as you
can see your words have impact let's
cheer ginger on and and share others on
in the comments who are going through
their own Journeys and I really
appreciate all of you guys sharing your
thoughts your tips your struggles in the
comments as well and Ginger keep it up
two milligrams today good luck yeah I'm
looking forward to hearing about it and
I I really do hope that the side effects
aren't too bad for you and you continue
to to be have that smile on your face
that's what we want to see oh thanks
Abby this was this was great and I'm
really looking forward to our next chat
and that John and Stacy comment is going
to stay at the back of my head mine too
long always yeah always I think as we
consume ozampic content in the media
through celebrity culture I think we
always have to have that in the back of
our mind as a bit of a threat you know
it's a bit of a threat to all of us and
it harms all of us when we let that
become the The Narrative that this is
what a healthy body looks like so just
keep that in mind everyone I definitely
am and I think you should too as well
Ginger will do all right Ginger thank
you so much
bye and all that notes guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it a thumbs up subscribe to this
Channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]